welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and with the
trailer for Morbius now our worldwide I
thought I'd do a breakdown of everything
we know about the film throughout this
video we'll be discussing its release
date cast and how it connects to the MCU
there's lots of questions surrounding
the release as it's the first
spider-verse film since the new sony
disney deal and in this video we're
going to be breaking down everything you
need to know about how the two entities
are connected going forward now there
may be some spoilers here so if you
don't want anything potentially ruined
about the movie and some of its cameos
then I highly suggest that you turn off
now without the way I just want to give
a huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into our breakdown of
Morbius okay so Morbius is due to be
released on the 31st of July this year
originally the film was going to be
released on the 10th of the same month
however after the Ghostbusters reboot
slash sequel was announced the web heads
over at the studio decided to push back
the upcoming film so that I could have
an opening weekend all to itself this
also puts a bang in the middle of the
summer blockbuster season and after
venom successful theatrical run it makes
sense to drop the movie at a time when
it can get the most exposure especially
due to the lack of competition that
doesn't mean that it's gonna be a
surefire hit though as to net releases
two weeks before Morbius and Disney's
Jungle Cruise drops on the 24th so yeah
it does have some competition but
luckily it's coming out at a time when
people tend to go to the movies a lot
more so it does have a good shot
recapturing the buzz centered around its
predecessor from the trailer we can see
that Sony are playing of the fact it's
attached to the MCU which will hopefully
drum up a lot of attention for it we'll
get into this later in the breakdown but
apparently Marvel Studios aren't happy
with the fact that this studio is
shooting for an R rating and they are
carefully proceeding with whether to
connect things on their end we'll just
leave it up to Sony to drop Easter eggs
to the larger MCU we don't know for
definite if we will be getting a
no-holds-barred Morbius movie
for a film that's about a living vampire
that hunts humans and drinks their blood
you would think that it would naturally
be more violent than the majority of
comic book movies that we get venom was
originally rumoured to be an RA at film
however Sony apparently cut things out
of the movie in order to play it safe
and appeal to the mass market and it is
likely that Morbius will do the same
personally I think because of the
financial success of venom Sony will be
wanting to stick to the formula and keep
things as toned down as possible as for
the plot though we don't know the
specifics just yet the film is expected
to stick relatively closely to Morbius
his origin story which we do pretty much
see play out in the trailer I say stick
to it I get like a Spider Man stick
thing but but yeah spider-man's not
gonna be part of his already in story so
that's it's close enough anyway in case
you don't know Morbius is actually a
Nobel prize-winning biologist named
Michael who suffers from a rare blood
condition we see this in the trailer and
it leaves him disabled and close to
death at all points trying to cure he
gives himself an experimental treatment
that involves injecting vampire bat DNA
directly into his veins
another secures him it also curses him
with something far worse this transforms
him into a sort of vampire that is
weakened by sunlight and Morbius must
feed on blood in order to survive and he
quickly becomes a predator of the night
where Morbius differs from your typical
Count Dracula is that he only feeds on
the blood of bad people and this is sort
of turned him into an antihero
we saw a very similar aesthetic in venom
with Eddie Brock agreeing to only eat
the evil doers of the world at the end
of the movie and this pop motif will
likely reappear here as for the cast
list there's actually a couple of big
names attached to the movie and it's
bringing in a lot of new names to the
Marvel fold this includes of course
Jared Leto as well as Adria or Jonah who
will be playing his fiancee Matt Smith
is also playing crown a villain from the
comic books that will go head-to-head
with the character Tyrese Gibson is also
in it and he's the actor that let it
slip that this was connected to the MCU
Gibson is playing an FBI agent named
agent Simon Stroud
who you may know from the comics has
been someone that hunted Mobius in
several runs Gibson reportedly has
signed a three-picture deal
so if Mobius gets a sequel it is likely
that this pop point will pop up before
we get in to have the movie connects to
the MCU I just want to let you know
we're giving away a free copy of Joker
to one lucky random subscriber all you
have to do to be in with the chance of
winning is like the video subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts on
Morbius in the comments section below
the one is gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of January and the set will be
shipped out from the intro ever get
surprised it's the best of luck to
everyone he takes part now as for how
Mobius connects to the MCU is actually a
lot in the air in regards to the film
both on screen and behind the scenes on
Sunday it was leaked that the character
would pass a spider-man poster at one
point that had murderer written across
it this was initially thought to be fake
because the poster is a screenshot from
the loading screen of the PlayStation
spider-man game however since the
release of the trailer we do know that
this is indeed in the film why is such a
strange image and what exactly is going
on with it well though it is the Raimi
suit that was part of the DLC for the
game the fact that it has murderer
scrawled across it it's clearly hinting
at the fact that this is referencing the
Tom Holland wall-crawler when Sony and
Disney were renegotiating the spider-man
deal the companies came to an agreement
that their spider-verse would be able to
drop nods to the larger elements of the
MCU and also feature cameos from certain
actors this is clearly gone ahead but
that doesn't mean it's as easy as saying
they're all connected even with a
knowable appearance by the vulture
according to inside sources that we
cannot verify so do take this with a
pinch of salt Sony are going to be
referencing the MCU quite a lot but this
won't be going both ways Disney are
apparently only going to pay lip service
to Morbius and venom in the spider-man
movies that they produce and they will
restrict this completely in their other
solo properties so no it is unlikely
that we will see venom bumping into
Doctor Strange anytime soon however at
least they're allowed to reference and
interact with them now and I did enjoy
seeing Michael Keaton pop up at the end
of the
however I think they're missing a big
opportunity here with the fact that
Blaine is going to be part of the Marvel
Universe relatively soon it makes a lot
of sense that comic books biggest
Vampire Hunter is gonna go up against
its biggest vampire so I am hoping that
Disney start playing ball with the
studio and also dropping a few nuts to
them as well earlier in the week
dr. movie news also dropped a tweet that
said not only will JK Simmons have a
supporting role but spider-man will have
a presence in the film via wanted
posters thus taking place after far from
home the MCU and spider-verse are
bridged so now that we can verify that
the spider-man poster is indeed in the
film it does seem likely that the JK
Simmons part is true as well this is an
awesome way just to tie everything
together but it kind of makes me wonder
how they're gonna do it Simmons was
obviously a huge part of the Raimi
trilogy and with the Raimi poster being
there it could also mean that Sony are
hinting at the larger multiverse and how
different versions of the characters
could exist across different platforms I
could be reading way too much into that
but who knows maybe someone just had a
loading screen image lying around and
they quickly just snapped together this
it does seem weird that they used to
spider-man loading screen though which
yet I still find that a bit funny I mean
if you fire that man just fat he's
taking your money Sony he's the real
villain here no but anyway now due to
the time period that we can gather from
the poster it does appear that this will
take place post snap and after the
events of endgame this could explain how
the vulture is now out and about in the
world as he's likely served his sentence
at this point because of the five-year
time jump venom didn't mention a snap at
all because they simply weren't allowed
to so that film will now likely sit
between the events of Home Coming and
infinity war so if you like me and just
want to put your blu-rays in the right
order
that's what I'd suggest as for the
trailer itself it does look like Sony
are keeping up their darker aesthetic
and there's a lot of darkness and shadow
using it to really give us the true
vision of Morbius that we've been
waiting for I really do hope that they
go with an r/a vision and it's nice that
we got to see Batman and Joker on screen
at the same time
I'm hopeful that this can deliver but
I'm dialing back my expectations because
hey it's Sony and you just never know
Leo did kind of let me down with Suicide
Squad but I do know he can be a
phenomenal actor so I am hoping that in
this role he can really deliver I guess
we'll find out soon enough and it's time
to count down the days or nights hey cuz
he's nocturnal for the movies a release
on July 31st
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on Morbius and if you're
excited for the movie leave them in the
comments below and if you enjoyed this
video and please give it a thumbs up or
I'll suck your blood I won't make sure
and make sure you check out our full
breakdown of the news that the defenders
are going to be used in Marvel
properties we talked about how they
could appear and why it's taken so long
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more you can support
the show by subscribing to us on patreon
and if you want to come chat to us after
the video you can join our discord
server in the description below or
follow us on twitter at definition
whitey that's the best way to keep up to
date with everything we do at heavy
spoilers and hopefully you see over
there very soon this is a channel for
people who are super into superheroes so
if that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
[Music]